Hi, I'm Andrea Crawford with IBM Cloud
and we're going talk about cloud migration.
Take a look at this picture here.
We have enterprise infrastructure.
This is typically where a lot of our compute workloads are
bare metal, enterprise core systems, mainframe,
on-premises data center.
We have private cloud over here,
also on-premises, but cloud capabilities in full effect.
And then we have public cloud,
this is off-premises cloud capabilities.
Now, many of our enterprises are still struggling to get workloads
off their enterprise infrastructure  and on to the cloud.
So, when we migrate enterprise workloads
to private or public, we call that migration.
And this is all about understanding enterprise workloads
and their characteristics in terms of whether they should land
on-premises cloud,
or off-premises public cloud.
We also have "modernize".
There could be some workloads over here that we might be able to
re-factor, if you will.
Think about a mainframe: monolithic code
- if we could put some API's on top of that
to expose core business functions,
we might be able to modernize functions in a way where
those API’s might be able to live here.
And then we have our third use-case, "build native".
For those workloads that live over here,
if we have an opportunity to
do things over in a way where we could design
cloud-native apps to live either here or here,
we would be able to infuse qualities like
correlation ID's
to track microservices and where traffic flows,
we would be able to leverage a lot of the core functions for load balancing
and service management here in the clouds.
The clouds offer some core capabilities within the platform
so that we can free up some of the logistics in the application layer
so that we can be more innovative.
Which brings me to the benefits.
So, moving, migrating, modernizing
applications to the cloud is cost effective.
So, we can lower our costs specifically around public,
around OpEx (operating expense),
and being able to let our cloud providers
take care of a lot of the management of those workloads.
Another benefit is scalability,
because cloud heavily leverages virtualization
and the ability to do things like Cloud Foundry and Kubernetes,
we can leverage the core services in those particular models,
but we also have the flexibility to bare metal,
and even virtual machines.
Another benefit is security.
One of the great things about cloud is
we don't have to worry about a lot of the core
services that we would have had to worry about over here.
A lot of our cloud providers nowadays
actually address a lot of the security concerns.
Where you have compliance regulation, data concerns,
these are services that can be provided here.
We also have, as our last benefit, "accelerated adoption".
So, by leveraging the services in the cloud,
like service routing, service discovery, and load balancing,
we don't have to worry about that at the application level.
So, we really start to understand why enterprises
are really chomping at the bit
to move workloads from here to here, or here.
And that is cloud migration.
Thanks for watching this video.
Be sure to "like" and subscribe,
if you have any questions or comments drop a line below.